>> Lawrence: THERE IS NO END IN
SIGHT WHEN IT DOCUMENTS GUN
VIOLENCE IN CHICAGO JUST THIS
WEEKEND 60 PEOPLE WERE SHOT 11
OF THOSE VICTIMS WERE UNDER THE
AGE OF 18.
JOE BIDEN WOULD TELL YOU THAT HE
CARES ABOUT THE KIDS WHEN IT
COMES TO COVID.
AFTER ALL, THAT'S WHY IS HE
PUSHING MASKS, VACCINATIONS IN
SCHOOLS.
BUT JUST THIS YEAR MORE KIDS
HAVE BEEN SHOT IN CHICAGO ALONE
THAN HAVE DIED OF COVID IN THE
WHOLE COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO THE CHICAGO P.D. AT
LEAST 261 KIDS HAVE BEEN SHOT IN
CHICAGO THIS YEAR.
NOW COMPARE THAT TO 214 COVID
RELATED DEATHS.
THE LIFE OF EVERY CHILD IS
IMPORTANT.
AND EACH DEATH IS A TRAGEDY.
NO MATTER HOW THEY DIED.
SO WHY DOES IT FEEL LIKE JOE
BIDEN IS ONLY FRUSTRATED ABOUT
COVID?
JOINING ME NOW IS THE FOUNDER OF
BLACK GUNS MATTER.
THIS IS A TOPIC NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART, YOUR HEART.
WHY IS IT ANY INTEREST IN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
ON THIS ISSUE?
I MEAN, HE TALKS ABOUT
VACCINATION AND MASKING AND
LOCKDOWNS AND KEEPING PEOPLE
SAFE.
BUT THE KIDS THAT ARE BEING
SHOT, EVERY SINGLE DAY, NOT A
WORD.
>> WELL, BECAUSE JOE BIDEN
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT BLACK PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT COMPLICATED.
HE SPENT MOST OF HIS POLITICAL
CAREER LOCKING BLACK PEOPLE UP.
JOE BIDEN, EVEN WHEN HE WAS
FAMOUSLY RUNNING TO BE THE, ARE
YOU KNOW, VICE PRESIDENT, YOU
KNOW, SAID OBAMA, YOU KNOW, HE
IS ONE OF THE CLEAN ONES.
JOE BIDEN HAS ZERO INTEREST THIS
FACADE, YOU KNOW, HE IS ART OF
THAT CABAL.
HE IS NOW WITH THE OPPOSITE
TEAM.
I THINK IN ESSENCE HE IS JUST
SHOWING US EXACTLY WHO HE IS.
HE HAS SHOWN US FOR HALF A
CENTURY, I THINK IS HE BEING
MORE BRAZEN WITH IT YOU SAW A
FEW DAYS AGO WHERE HE LITERALLY
TOLD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT,
YOU KNOW, I'M GETTING TIRED OF
NOT BEING AS MUCH AS A TIE RANT
WHEN I WANT TO BE WHEN HE TALKS
ABOUT OUR PATIENCE IS WEARING
THIN.
SO, THIS IS PAR FOR THE COURSE
FOR JOE BIDEN AND NOT EVEN JUST
JOE BIDEN.
YOU GOT TO LOOK AT LORI
LIGHTFOOT OVER IN CHICAGO.
YOU GOT ALL THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
DYING.
>> THIS IS THE SAME PERSON THAT
SAID, YOU KNOW, WAS ALL LAST
YEAR WITH THE FAKE WOKE, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO DEFUND THE
POLICE.
WE NEED ALL OF THIS COVID MONEY
THAT SHE JUST REALLOCATED RIGHT
INTO THE POLICE DEPARTMENT BUT
NOTHING FOR DEVELOPING THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IMPACTED BY
THIS NEGLIGENCE IN REGARDS TO,
YOU KNOW, IRRESPONSIBLE GUN
OWNERSHIP.
THIS IS PAR FOR THE COURSE FOR
DEMOCRATS.
AND THE SIMPLE ANSWER IS, JOE
BIDEN DOESN'T CARE ABOUT BLACK
PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY THE BLACK
PEOPLE AND YOUTH IN CHICAGO.
>> Lawrence: THIS IS WHEN IT
GETS TROUBLING TO ME IT'S NOT
JUST JOE BIDEN THE WHOLE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THEY HAVE BEEN
COMPLETE FAILURES WHEN IT COMES
TO THE COMMUNITY.
YOU HAVE GOT KIM FOXX.
THE JUDGES THERE, CITY COUNCIL.
ALL DEMOCRATS THEY RUN IT THEN I
LOOK AT MY REPUBLICANS BROTHERS
AND CITIESERS YOU KNOW, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE THIS BAD.
IF THEY ARE THIS BAD, WHY CAN'T
YOU BEAT THEM?
I MEAN, IT'S JUST THIS SIMPLE?
THESE PEOPLE ARE CRYING OUT FOR
HELP.
AND THEY ARE WILLING TO ACCEPT
ANYBODY THAT IS PROVOKING CHANGE
AND LIBERTY AND CHOOSING LIFE
OVER ANYTHING.
WHY CAN'T YOU BEAT THESE BAD
CANDIDATES?
>> THEY CAN'T BEAT THE BAD
CANDIDATES BECAUSE THERE IS
STILL A LOT OF AND, AGAIN, I'M
GOING TO SAY THE TRUTH AND I
DON'T WANT TO OFFEND BUT SOME
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE OFFENDED
BY THIS.
THE REALITY IS A LOT OF THE OLD
GUARD ON THE RIGHT SIDE, ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
ON OUR LIBERTARIAN SIDE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO GO INTO
PLACES THAT ARE SCARY OR WHERE
THE OTHER ARE.
OTHERS ARE.
YOU HAVE CANDIDATES LIKE KIM
KLACIK THAT RAN OUT IN
BALTIMORE, RAISED MILLION
DOLLARS BY TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT
WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN THAT
DEMOCRATICALLY RAN CITY OF
BALTIMORE.
YOU HAVE OTHER PEOPLE ATTACKING
HER, SAYING THAT SHE SHOULDN'T
RUN IN PLACES THAT ARE
UNWINNABLE.
>> Lawrence: WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
>> RIGHT.
WELL, AMERICA IS UNWINNABLE WHEN
WE WENT UP AGAINST THE BRITISH
FOLKS.
YOU KNOW, WHEN PEOPLE WERE FAGHT
FROM CAPTIVITY DURING
ENSLAVEMENT IN AMERICA, HAIR
YACHT TUBMAN WAS FIGHTS
UNWINNABLE FIGHT.
JOHN F. KENNEDY ASKING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TATTOO NOT, YOU
KNOW, WORRY ABOUT JUST WHAT
THEIR COUNTRY CAN DO FOR THEM
BUT WHAT THEY CAN DO FOR THEIR
COUNTRY.  THAT WAS UNWINNABLE.
THAT THIS IS THE MENTALITY THAT
WE HAVE ALLOWED TO FESTER ON THE
RIGHT.
A LOT OF THAT IN THESE
DEMOCRATICALLY RAN CITIES I
UNDERSTAND IT.
I JUST DISAGREE WITH IT.
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT WE
ACCEPT THAT WELL, IT'S BEEN THIS
WAY FOR THIS LONG.
IF THE FOUNDING FATHERS TO THIS
NATION WOULD HAVE ACCEPT IT THAT
WAY WE WOULD BE SPEAKING FRENCH
RIGHT NOW, SO THE REALITY IS,
YOU KNOW, IT'S A VICTIM AND, YOU
KNOW, DEFEATIST MENTALITY THAT
WE ON THE RIGHT HAVE TO STOP.
IF WE WANT TO SAVE THE REPUBLIC.
>> Lawrence: IF YOU CAN'T SELL
FREEDOM AND LIBERTY THEN MAYBE
YOU SHOULDN'T BE IN THE FIGHT,
BROTHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING ON
THE PROGRAM.
I